[SPEAKER_01]: Folsum is pulling to the charm.
[SPEAKER_00]: That actually is a good feat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Reverse spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but identify it too so you know what to pretend.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're my best friend.
[SPEAKER_00]: He doesn't have that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, let's see about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't tap the glass.
[SPEAKER_04]: Third of Wealsun, the party continues walking down the rickety staircase very early in the morning with Fearfield.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so...
[SPEAKER_04]: In the darkness, the strange whisperings of people.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys really can't tell who it is, who's talking, but there's whisperings among various...
[SPEAKER_04]: Groups behind you.
[SPEAKER_04]: You're focused on moving down the ledge, okay?
[SPEAKER_04]: You go about 300 yards down this rickety thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have we all crossed the bridge by now?
[SPEAKER_04]: There is no bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're walking above this chasm.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like an underground river, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And there's this little thing on top of it that kind of goes on the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does it go downwards?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or is it pretty straight?
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does it go straight or does it go down?
[SPEAKER_04]: It goes down.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's actually going down and going around curves and this tunnel kind of curves.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like the Goblin King there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_04]: Except with C's.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so what happens is you take a turn, all right, and
[SPEAKER_04]: Off in the distance, and I would say this is about 100 feet away, you see torchlight.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: So cover up my light.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cover up the shield.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge up next to me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, hang on, not yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: You haven't turned the path.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I motion for gouge to come up next to me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, point out the...
[SPEAKER_04]: Torch light.
[SPEAKER_04]: You see a form off in the distance down off the platform walk past.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can't make it out.
[SPEAKER_04]: It looks like a human, humanoid, whatever.
[SPEAKER_04]: But they walk past the torch and into another room.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Motion to let these guys know that there's something down there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to move ahead under extreme stealth as best I can.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I'm going to pass.
[SPEAKER_03]: My light cover.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they walked.
[SPEAKER_00]: So they're off of the thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: It doesn't look like they're... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: It looks like what happens is the path ends and there is a...
[SPEAKER_04]: Tunnel.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And some kind of a chamber beyond it.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't know how big it is.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, it's just you can see the entrance and somebody walks past that entrance in the torchlight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, will I be able to stealth up there or they walk by the torchlight?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, it's pitch black again with his shield out.
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_04]: Here to there, it's dark.
[SPEAKER_04]: In fact, with the thing covered up, you see nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, so I couldn't even stealth up there because I can't even see what I'm doing.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can go by hand up that way if you want to.
[SPEAKER_04]: He's in the way.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's dark, but you can make that journey.
[SPEAKER_04]: You've done things like this before.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not the most comfortable thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Usually you're in the moonlight or you have some little bit of moonlight that you can see, but you see the torch, you have the distance, and you can feel the platform as you move forward.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll a 20-sided die.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, as you walk along this path, obviously the path has kind of gone down a little bit from the height of it.
[SPEAKER_04]: You've probably dropped in the last 200 yards, 300 yards, about 20, 25 feet closer to the water.
[SPEAKER_04]: Your ears pick up something, break the water, below you, and it's big.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then you hear its tail splash.
[SPEAKER_00]: Something's down there.
Got it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's the other lady?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the two of the two women, and so I married an ex-murder, the two that are fighting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Susan Sarandon.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are they in close enough proximity where I can talk to them, but they're too far ahead?
[SPEAKER_02]: They're too far ahead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Got Nancy Travis.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'm the one closest with the Toli guy that's ganged.
[SPEAKER_02]: I need to tell you guys something.
[SPEAKER_02]: They can't hear it.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys want to come?
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll leave if everybody else needs to get help.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you guys go up there and these two can hear.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't whisper, we've got to get the recording.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to stop where we're going right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's something down there and there's something big down there splashing around in the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: What?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know, but I heard a tail splashing against the sides of the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: How did you hear it and we didn't?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm familiar with the sea and all that stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ranger.
[SPEAKER_01]: It doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're saying there's something down there, but that's about 60 feet down.
[SPEAKER_02]: We've been slowly descending.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are slowly descending.
[SPEAKER_01]: How far down is it now?
[SPEAKER_04]: Maybe 30 yards down.
[SPEAKER_04]: 30 feet down.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to look down there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Roll Perception.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you know anything about any big creatures in the water?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I'll- I have a plus three for perception.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you're next close in line to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: 16, 17, 19.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, I'll come and say something to you in private in a second, but I want to answer the question.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, there are many things in the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's always a bigger picture.
[SPEAKER_04]: With your Improvision, you see a creature that you would say was a shark, except it's 40 feet long, swimming, turning around, and then swimming back down towards the direction you're going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it seem to notice us?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's just patrolling this little rivulet and moving up and down.
[SPEAKER_04]: So a large shark, huge shark.
[SPEAKER_04]: Normal sharks are 10 feet long.
[SPEAKER_04]: Big ones.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you say it's 40 feet long?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so this is a really big cavern.
[SPEAKER_04]: If a 40 feet shark is... Yeah, I mean, the cavern is wide.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's at least, you know, 40, 50 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he can kind of go in and he's basically patrolling.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hunting, maybe.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Shut the fuck up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't whisper.
You can say normal.
I say this lightly.
[SPEAKER_01]: What if it got you that too?
[SPEAKER_01]: We have to continue.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a large shark patrolling.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whoever can get to a barrel first, if you see a barrel, crack it open and throw it into the water.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, I mean, or sprinkle it, whatever the hell you gotta do.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's either gonna work...
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we're all fucked, including Fairwin, in which case I would suggest that you push his ass off into the water first.
[SPEAKER_05]: Understandable.
[SPEAKER_05]: Fairwin, do you have any, like, magic dust on ya?
[SPEAKER_05]: In your pockets, perchance?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think I actually have a little.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we go?
[SPEAKER_00]: You go.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I have a little serum full of the yellow stuff that I took with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: You didn't bring that with you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Really?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I don't think you brought that with you.
[SPEAKER_04]: He says, What did I say?
[SPEAKER_01]: We're still going forward.
[SPEAKER_04]: Push me off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: If this thing starts to like crawl out of the water on like four legs.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think- It won't crawl out of the water.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then I'm not too worried about it as long as- It sounds like the sahuagin have their pets patrolling the area.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, of course they do.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they're all fascinated with sharks and shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is this something I could recognize from him telling me this giant shark or something I wouldn't have knowledge on?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you've heard tales.
[SPEAKER_04]: In fact, the old fisherman would talk about-
[SPEAKER_04]: Giant beasts, 40 feet long, that can eat a man with one bite.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cut him in half, so it's possible.
[SPEAKER_04]: But you have never seen one yourself.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, most sharks around this area, the big ones are like 10 feet lost.
[SPEAKER_01]: Listen, we still continue forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: If there's a fight, whoever can get to any of the barrels, crack one open, start sprinkling whatever the hell's inside into the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then just go quietly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I say in Sule, I say, you'll never bet another woman again if you make a sound.
[SPEAKER_04]: Unfortunately, his witty repartee is not there because he's ballgagged.
[SPEAKER_04]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, are you guys going to move forward or are you guys waiting for Gouge to give the go ahead?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, if we were waiting for Gouge before, then we're still waiting.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, Gouge says he's going to crawl ahead by himself.
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus actually says back to you guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: I have a feeling he goes, shut up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I feel like I can get to Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, there's no point trying to get up and warn Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge is doing Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we can tell Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, you can if you want to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, are we next to Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_04]: Tyrus is like 20 feet ahead of you guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you go up and tell Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_00]: You gotta go past him.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you stay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to use my cantrip message to tell Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, can you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Message does that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So come with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: You should let me have that spot.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a cantrip.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can't get it.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have to get it as a cantrip.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right, so you creep ahead, and I'm gonna do you in a second, all right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow, that's bad.
[SPEAKER_04]: It is bad.
[SPEAKER_04]: What fire is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Lower Rogue.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Shitty.
[SPEAKER_04]: You get a message.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can't hear this.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just go over there.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll come back in a second.
[SPEAKER_04]: A voice comes into your head.
[SPEAKER_04]: Luckily, you've had to deal with this before.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is how Folsum points at you and talks to you from across a room.
[SPEAKER_04]: Normally, it's something very, very, I would say childish and ridiculous.
[SPEAKER_04]: He kind of tells you jokes about women, officers, other things like that, using this belt.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is a little more serious.
[SPEAKER_05]: Tyrus, this is not a joke about women or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Underneath the water, we've learned that there is a 40-foot giant shark underneath us right now.
[SPEAKER_05]: One of the Sahuagin's pets.
[SPEAKER_05]: We are shaking in our boots standing above this bridge in the water just circling around us.
[SPEAKER_05]: Merrick heard a tail slap.
[SPEAKER_05]: Jude fully saw it.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm letting you know that maybe we should advance a little bit ahead maybe just so we're out of this area because maybe it's not the safest environment right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or, at the very least, don't fall in the water.
[SPEAKER_04]: Don't go in the water.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: And there's no way I can see Gouge?
[SPEAKER_05]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: You do not see Gouge.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're fine, dude.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're good.
[SPEAKER_03]: G, you're good.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're good.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so let me do gouge here real fast.
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys go back in.
[SPEAKER_04]: You got an eye?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Want me to grab one?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh yeah, you're stealthin'.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.